what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alvey and it's John Humphrey over here
so we literally just came back from
watching mother how this we're gonna do
this talk is will give like a
non-spoiler review in the first few
minutes but really you can't I just
don't see how you can properly give a
actually express your opinion about this
movie unless you get into some spoiler
territory so will do I feel like most
I'm probably more time on spoilers and
then not spoil their part of this movie
but you know wipe your got pumpkin spice
pumpkin spice where you on my hand I
don't worry up on John's overuse okay so
when was when we were watching this
movie you know I'll just tell you how I
feel I in some ways I loved this movie I
kind of it's a rare movie where I love
and hate this movie simultaneous
basically it's like both feelings
definitely exist and like it's ballsy
its inventive its creative and you know
you hear people saying it's a film that
people are gonna be talking about that
people are gonna be speculating about
and by the time it was done yeah
everyone in the theater was just
sticking around talking about the movie
and what they thought about it you get I
get here some people saying what they
thought of how great it was I heard
someone and behind me saying like so I
guess Darren Aronofsky just wanted to
make the worst movie of the year you
know yeah there's a it's a lot of
different conflicting opinions John
Hodge how do you feel um I mean I the
opposite of enjoyed most every second of
the experience of almost any of it but I
am kind of with you in the sense that I
think there's a ton to appreciate and I
think there's a lot of skill at work I
think it's super effective like the way
I would describe this movie is effective
because I definitely felt everything I
think they wanted me to feel like it it
definitely took me for a journey and it
plucked a lot of my emotional chords and
and the thing
that Jennifer Lawrence has to go through
just the kind of the way in which you
have this one character who's trying to
kind of mitigate or keep everything
together while no one pays any attention
to them it's just you know an easy place
to relate to so the movies messy and
chaotic but that's part of its
brilliance and its intention at the same
time you know cuz this film does put you
in he does that like Darren Aronofsky
quiet like I to me this felt like Darren
Aronofsky's Noah meets Black Swan with a
lot more of the Bible being covered
that's pretty much how I felt when I was
watching this film and it puts you in
the shoes of Jennifer Lawrence's
character who just named mother right
that's her like credited name his mother
no one has any actual names anybody
hardly by name yeah she doesn't have an
actual name and no one's credited with
an actual name in this movie so she goes
by mother and you're in her shoes the
whole time a lot of tracking shots of
her the cameras primarily on her for
like 90% of this film he even 95 percent
of this movie yeah you're pretty close
on her most of the time you know you're
like here you know like most of the time
on her except for when she like walks
far out of out of frame and at first the
one the first like 15 minutes of this
film I thought that directing and
editing was actually really frustrating
to sit through it's it was kind of a
little agonizing actually but then as if
some progressed you settled into the
style and the mood and the tone that
Darren Aronofsky's going for and there's
some really powerful performances here
Jennifer Lawrence kills it I think
Jennifer Lawrence it's an amazing job in
this movie it's funny every time every
time I think I'm sick of her I see
another one of her movies and I'm like
wow yeah you you're you got chops sister
but this this is one of those so you
know because like we get her our Hunger
Games and our passengers in her x-men
but this is like oh this is like
Winter's Bone Jennifer Lawrence Jennifer
Lawrence and the performance is is what
we're here at sea and Javier Bardem is
does a really great job - yeah and by
the end of this film just the fact that
these actors were so game for this we're
as film because you know that you hear
people say that yeah your people say
this is not surprised at all that
anybody wanted to do this I'm sure they
were all champing at the bit are you
kidding really no I think it goes down
some pretty crazy parts in the in the
finale where it's it's a little bit like
risque for an actor to be a part of
because there are some truly shocking
parts where you know yeah I get you as
much as people think the movies not as
much as some people feel like this
movie's open to interpretation some
people feel like it means nothing some
people feel like it's very crystal clear
to cut on what the whole movie means at
the end of day if you've been hearing
people say this film is weird and gets
crazy in the finale I did not expect it
I did not expect to walk away from this
movie going wow it was weirder and
crazier than I thought yes it has that's
instead of doing the older style thing
where the this the the pace is
deliberate and it does not slow burn but
it builds over time but this isn't one
of those older type movies where it's
pretty normal for most of it in the very
end it gets crazy yeah this like it
steadily ramps up the jarring weirdness
of it all you know so that by the time
you're in the middle you're like okay
things are pretty weird right now that's
going on then by the time you get to the
end you're like what is happening Hannah
spec the first half feels like a real
movie the first half feels like a legit
film you know the parts of the trailer
that they show you of Javier Bardem and
Jennifer Lawrence letting in these two
strangers into their home and they're
kind of weird and intrusive and hungrier
Bardem is taking a really strong liking
to them and I I want to make this very
clear a lot of people thought this is
just gonna be a Rosemary's Baby remake
and while there are some similar things
on paper I saw Rosemary's Baby last week
I can tell you from freshly watching
Rosemary's Baby this is very much its
own thing very good yeah there are
things that are similar but yeah but no
matters so watch that are so different
in this movie
I was ya watching and I was a lot more
reminded of Andres allows Sookie's
possession which I don't know if how
many people in our audience have seen
that but I'm sure some of you have and
and that movie has a certain jarring
obtuse quality that then I thought this
movie shared a lot more with than
Rosemary's Baby and even though I saw
some of that but yeah well the first
half of this movie it feels like the
real a real movie where you can feel
like it's building towards something
yeah yeah and Ed Harris fantastic job in
the film - Michelle Pfeiffer it was
great to see Michelle Pfeiffer doing a
role where you're like with a lot of
people cuz cuz Donald Gleason and Brian
Gleason are both in it too and and
Stephen McHattie who's a great you know
character actress yeah and everybody
shows up and does a great job like the
roles are all very strange and very
specific but there's not a member of the
cast I wasn't impressed by it's just the
last half of the movie feels like okay
this is a chaotic it feels like Darren
Aronofsky's point of views towards
society and religion put into this
metaphorical movie you feel is like
diary and angry thoughts she is
flattered on the screen you know when
you're watching it because the first
half feels like a movie and the last
half feels more like his messages all
being thrown at you and then for a while
you're like it gets to a point where you
start trying to like interpret things
but by the time it gets to the end of
the movie I felt like the message was
pretty crystal clear on what the movie
was about and what he was this was like
some people really try to interpret it
and I haven't heard any interpretations
yet I we we just got back from the
feeder I haven't read anything or watch
the video of what someone thinks this
movies about but from coming from a we
grew up in Catholic school together like
from 1st to 8th grade to me it was
pretty crystal clear what the hell the
movie was talking about by the time we
got to the end I was like in the art in
the you know pretense versus art debate
I don't think the the pretense is really
the side this falls on because I
can tell what he thinks half Allard it's
not like it's empty imagery for for not
money it's not like it's giving you a
bunch of scenes and going I don't know
figure it out yeah it's it definitely
seen like some absolutely happy idea and
you're free to draw and extrapolate your
own meanings out of it because I'm sure
that there's more than one way to look
at this but there is one metaphor
throughout that that is very yes seems
very good sir very apparent honest right
down to the way that the credits are
named I wouldn't give this movie a
consensus I would say that it's
definitely engaging and even though it's
kind of slow it's at first it's still
very engaging it lives up to the word
you hear of everyone saying it gets
crazy and it's one of those movies where
it's really just a matter of the viewer
like I don't I wouldn't trust a rotten
tomatos consensus off of a film like
this you just gotta go see it for
yourself and form your own personal okay
I mean you can say about any movie and
Rotten Tomatoes but this movie
specifically do not rely on like what
are the critics saying you just gotta
find out for yourself what you think
about the film well yes this is one of
those movies that isn't bound to a
familiar formula we can judge based on
other movies that have done it worried
you know like you can look at this movie
and go yes the acting is really good and
yes the writing is interesting and yes
you know the the set design is a sound
designs are great sound design is great
attainable scales are fantastic yeah
about every box you can check for
somebody's job on this movie it's well
done it's polished it looks good and it
comes together and yeah the the story in
and of itself is the that's the that's
the part because when it gets to the
last half of the movie when all the
chaos starts to ensue it's all a matter
of that personal viewers interpretation
of this is are they gonna take away the
religious metaphors are they gonna take
away the metaphors about Fame what are
they gonna create and relationships and
yeah like there's there's a lot of Miss
Yorkers in this movie well you know even
though it's chaotic it's kind of a good
blend I thought that that was a
fascinating part to me was it's kind of
a beautiful chaotic mess and at times
pretty disturbing stuff goes down it's
not filled with disturbing stuff but at
times disturb
stuff does go down boy and I feel like
for our spoiler part of this video we're
probably just gonna give like what we
viewed it as but we pretty much thought
like here's what was going on we watch
the movie yeah and I mean even if it's
not always visually going crazy most of
the movie is is viscerally uncomfortable
yeah in one way or another whether
you're you're really looking for a
catharsis because people kind of trample
all over Jennifer Lawrence through this
whole movie which is you see later kind
of as part of the point but you know
that creates I was it not that it's like
the babadook but I had a similar
experience where I'm like the sensory
parts of this movie are making me feel
very claustrophobic very frustrated yeah
you know and I think that's a valuable
thing to be able to do as a filmmaker
performance is just it's phenomenal on
this movie the the idea I mean I've said
it many times I love characters who's
just escalating hate to get [ __ ]
worse as the film Goods coming and of
keeping it get through you know like
just trying to be polite trying to be
nice and then it's like they're slowly
just reaching the boiling point yeah
yeah and when that finally happens thank
goodness for my viewing experience it
was like yes please like yeah something
yeah well yeah I would say go watch it
that definitely saved I'd say even if he
hated it and I loved it or I hate it and
he loves it like I think it's watch it
just you gotta go watch it and put a
frickin opinion down and to come so you
thinking me liking a movie doesn't
necessarily make it good or bad yeah
it's like even if I didn't like watching
this and I might never want to watch it
again I see I would I would I would
totally watch it again I I would want to
watch it tomorrow yeah I would
definitely be curious fascinating how
this movie aiders and maybe if I hate it
less the second time just like that
movie possession i sat through that
movie being like I hate this and then
you know afterward it did make me think
so I'm like maybe I should go back oh
yeah better day you know or on a
different day well yeah I think it's
just one hell of a fascinating
experience I love that people are
talking about this movie I love how
people are it's a movie that you just
you you don't just turn it off and just
be
yeah yeah like it's okay it's not that
move it leaves an impact it forces you
to think and feel stuff you know and
I've not seen anything like it and I've
seldom felt the feeling that it gave
down afterwards the only thing only
things that are slightly similar that
I've seen to this or other Darren Darren
Aronofsky bits about as far as it goes
you